JU-KAY KWEK: OK.
If there's one thing that you
guys take away from today's
session, it's on this slide.
Right?
It's really that simple.
What we're going to be talking
about today is big data.
Quantifying big data, talking
about some real-life use cases
for big data, right?
It's not very easy.
In fact, it can be a pain,
especially if your business is
actually solving some other
business problem.
We want to suggest that there
is a better way of doing big
data than some of the
methods that we've
seen out there today.
And what we want to show, with
the help of some of our
friends here, is how you can
do that with Google Cloud
Services and be very
successful building
applications on big data.
All right?
So, we're going to be handing
off a little bit.
I'm going to kick us off by
starting and talking about
what is big data.
We're not going to spend a whole
lot of time on this, but
I thought it would be fun to go
through a couple of quotes
from a few of our customers
and the businesses that we
work with who have to
deal with large
amounts of data, right?
So the first quote--
and Richard here will be talking
about them later on--
is from CenterParcs.
They're a hospitality company, a
pretty large one, in Europe.
How are hotel reservations for
Spain from New York compared
with this time last year?
That's a pretty precise slice
of a lot of business data.
Do we need to adjust our
marketing campaign and where?
That's a completely different
set of data that may come from
AdWords, DoubleClick, right?
Campaign data, and
then slicing that
to a specific region.
If you think about the nature
of this question, it's a
pretty precise one to ask of--
what we'll see later on-- is a
lot of data.
Which users who signed up last
quarter also advanced at least
three levels and purchased an
item worth more than $5?
Now, this is actually
a real question.
This comes from another of
our early customers.
They were actually in the
Sandbox yesterday.
You might have seen them.
Their name is Claritics.
They do user analytics
for mobile and social
applications.
So they deal with tens of
millions of users, hundreds of
millions of events a day.
And what they do, using Google
Cloud Services as a platform,
is they help their customers to
understand their own user
sets, with very, very detailed
questions like this, that help
them find cohorts of users
and target them
for specific actions.
One more.
By the time we prepared the
data, we'd forgotten what the
question was.
Anyone ever come up against
this before when you're
working with data?
This is a quote that literally
comes from one of Google's
largest AdWords customers.
These guys deal with hundreds
of gigabytes of data a day
from the logs that get
served from the ads.
And the reason this is really
important to them-- and
they've invested a lot in
infrastructure that helps them
in house, but it takes
a long time.
The reason this is really
important for them is they
need to calculate
things like ROI.
How much are we spending
in a given region?
And do we need to change that to
help the business increase?
So these are all really
important business questions
that are grounded on the basis
of really understanding,
getting insight from, large
amounts of data.
I pulled these up just to give
everyone here a level set.
What are we talking about?
This isn't an academic talk.
This is about solving real
business problems by getting
insights into data.
So I just want to go through
this quickly.
But again, in the spirit of
getting some terms and
quantifying things, what are
some of these trends?
As we step back from those
questions, what's going on in
business today?
As we've talked to a lot of
these customers and worked
with them, these are some of
the things that are common
themes that emerge.
They see opportunities.
Data is increasingly seen as
a core business asset.
It's not something that you
just manage with IT.
This is something that
marketing, your data analytics
team, your sales team need
to do their job well.
Increasingly, a lot of critical
business data is out
in the cloud.
Anybody use Salesforce here?
Lots of people.
That just gets going.
Think about social and so
on, Google Analytics.
New things are possible in
the cloud because of
infrastructure, algorithms.
I don't have to go into this.
But all of the things that you
saw from the keynote, many of
these things are only available
by using the cloud.
Many businesses recognize
that too.
There are use cases in terms
of sharing of data,
controlling access to data,
speed of decision making.
As you saw with this laptop
crash example, that's just a
small one, but the speed with
which you can move data around
really affects how people can
actually make use of data to
make good business decisions.
But there are a couple of
challenges as well.
Information growing
faster than the
ability to leverage it.
As you heard in [INAUDIBLE]
keynote this morning, and as
you saw from that chart of
Chrome adoption, since 2004--
if you see that spike-- it's
more users, more applications,
on more devices all
generating data.
It's tough for enterprises
to capture all that data.
Even more challenging is for
the many businesses that do
have BI and data warehousing
infrastructure, the way of
doing things before with star
schemas, lots of indexing,
proprietary hardware, what
we'll see is that it's
actually very hard for a lot
of these installations to
actually keep up with this
torrent of data.
So what do you do?
And finally, skills.
It's not just about money.
It's not just about
technology.
It's about building the teams.
It's about changing your
organization to adapt to these
new tools and skills.
As anyone here who's tried
to hire for, say, Hadoop
engineers, you know skills
are hard to come by.
So these are some of both the
opportunities as well as the
challenges that, as we've
talked to many of these
customers, are recurring themes
as we hear customers
thinking about big data.
So let's get concrete
about it.
What does big data actually
look like?
Some of the common
characteristics comes in all
different kinds--
structured, semi-structured,
unstructured data, emails,
tweets, so on.
We're often talking about
millions, if not
billions, of rows.
And what kind of
frequency, too?
Often, it's too large a process
on a single machine.
Sometimes it's even too large to
store on a single machine.
What do you do then?
It's got a high rate of growth,
and often, it's
growing every day.
I won't read off the list of
industries, but this is
representative of sets of
customers that we've talked to
who experience a lot of these
common challenges.
So let's look at a real-life
example of big data.
This is just a snapshot, just
to give you an idea, but if
anyone here has worked with
DoubleClick, this is a
snapshot of some of the
ad serving logs.
A couple of people do.
And as you can see, a single
row-- and I just took whatever
fit on my screen for this-- but
you actually get a lot of
data in DoubleClick.
It's everything from advertiser,
campaign, time
stamp, what was the impression,
where it was.
This is a snapshot
from Google's own
global marketing campaigns.
We scrubbed it and anonymized
it just to show you.
But just to give you some of the
numbers, because Google is
very representative of a large
advertiser or an agency.
This is a very common problem.
This is just from one week.
We have 300 gigabytes of data
generated from these logs.
They average about 6 billion
rows, and almost a billion
rows coming in every day.
So that's a lot of data
to deal with.
And for the reasons that I
mentioned before, the stakes
are pretty high in terms of
understanding what's going on
in terms of all those ads
and impressions served.
What if you had to query it?
How would you do that?
Fortunately--
and we'll just do a fun
little demo here--
I'm going to show you how we
can do this on BigQuery.
So this is the BigQuery
user interface.
It's just a simple utilitarian
interface meant for letting
analysts and developers query
against large data sets.
Some of you might have played
with this before.
What we're looking at here,
if you can see, is a daily
snapshot of that data.
And you can see the
schema here.
It's a pretty complex schema.
If we look at the details, you
can see a single day's data is
pretty large.
So what I'm going to do is
I'm just going to pull.
And we're going to take that
one day of data, and we're
just going to do
a simple count.
How many rows is in
this 30 gigabytes?
It's a little hard to read, but
that's just a little over
a billion rows.
It's pretty nice, though, that
we managed to count that in,
what, less than six seconds.
We'll do one more, and
then we'll move on.
What I'm doing here is I'm
actually taking, now, that
full week's worth of data that
you saw from the snapshot.
And what this query is doing is
basically it's saying, find
all the countries.
Count all of the impressions.
And then here's the interesting
one, count
distinct for user IDs to find
the unique impressions.
So it's not just all of the
impressions that were served.
It's find all those impressions
for the exact
number of people that actually
clicked on one of these
impressions.
And you can see there we just
processed about 177 gigabytes
of data to find this question.
Remember, 6 billion rows.
We just went through this for
a fairly arbitrary question
with no indexes or caching
to find this answer.
We got a nice list here.
We can see, for example, in the
United States, that's 200
something million impressions,
2 billion impressions
actually, 150 million
unique impressions.
So that's just one example of
how you can quickly get
insights from a very
large amount of
data using Cloud tools.
But this kind of begs the
question, if it's so easy, why
aren't more people doing this?
So let's take one more step
back, and let's look at what's
going on out there.
This is just one quote from one
analyst, but it sounds a
little optimistic I think.
But $3 billion to $16 billion
in five years is a little
optimistic.
But it just gives you a sense
of how much investment and
interest there is in big data
solutions out there.
And I just took a couple of
the keywords that you
typically read when you
come across big data.
So MapReduce, NoSQL, Hadoop,
what do you do with all of
this stuff?
So what we see is there's a lot
of questions being asked
about how exactly do you go
about, from the problem of
having a lot of data and
knowing you need to get
business insight, to actually
running that really quick
query and interrogating data?
Finding the valuable needle
in the haystack?
What we see is there are some
patterns starting to evolve.
If you think about the tools
that people are assembling to
deal with big data, you can
think of it as kind of a
software stack, an architectural
stack.
On the bottom, there's storage,
the ability to store
tremendous amounts of data.
Once you have the data, you need
to be able to transform
it, do things like ETL, prepare
it in the right
format, so that it's actually
useful and can
be loaded into tools.
As we just saw with BigQuery
there's query and analysis.
And then once you have
those insights,
what do you with them?
You have to serve them in the
form of an application or a
dashboard or a report.
So serving the results.
And if you see the two columns
here, on the right basically,
if any of you have a couple
million dollars in your budget
to spare, you can go out and
get a very fully featured,
very capable, on-premises,
proprietary
data warehouse appliance.
Lots of cores and everything
to do this work for you.
But if you have a couple million
spare in your budget,
there may be better things
to do with it.
On the other hand, we see a lot
of really good work being
done in the open source world.
So many of these terms
that you see here--
NoSQL databases, HDFS, Hadoop,
all the different modules--
there's a lot of great work
being done by the open source
community to enable you to set
up your own software stack.
The challenge there is it's
really, really complex.
If you've ever tried to set up
an HDFS cluster, run different
Hadoop nodes, and manage all of
that, the task of actually
managing all of that software
stack greatly exceeds the
amount of time you actually
spend doing analysis.
So to go back to that customer,
by the time we
actually got the data prepared,
we'd forgotten what
the question was.
Directly applies to this.
So what we want to suggest is
maybe there's a better way of
doing this.
And to talk about that, I'm
going to ask my colleague,
Navneet, to come up.
Navneet is the product manager
for Google Cloud Storage,
close associate of mine.
And he's going to walk us
through some of the tools that
you can use.
NAVNEET JONEJA: Thank
you, Ju-kay.
So we'd like to propose that a
better way to do big data is
really to leverage the cloud
and to use what we call
Composable Cloud Services.
So Cloud Services with very
specific functionality that
you can put together to solve
various problems so you have a
complete stack that solves your
entire big data problem.
Focus on the solution rather
than the infrastructure.
So you're not worried about
deploying a new stack,
learning new technology,
learning, frankly, a whole new
way of doing things.
But instead, you're focused
on the solution
you're trying to build.
And then to actually do things
you couldn't do before,
because you have access to
technology built by people
who've been doing this
for a while.
And then finally, to make it
cost effective, because you
pay only for what you use.
So rather than spending a few
million dollars on an
appliance, you store as
much data as you need.
You process it when
you need to.
And when you think that
answering a question is worth
your time and money, you
use the service.
So I want to kind of call out
what we internally often call
the virtuous cycle of data.
This is something which comes
back very often from our
customers in different forms
when they talk about what they
want to do with the
data they have.
So at a very fundamental level,
they want to build
great applications.
They want to learn about how
the application is serving
their users.
Collect a bunch of data.
Process that data, so they
actually have access to it in
a form where they can
make sense of it.
Analyze the data and
then iterate.
They want to improve the
application, generate more
data, improve the application,
and so on and so forth.
So we think that's a really
great way to think about
applications.
And so a lot of what we're going
to talk about today, in
terms of the cloud solution, is
going to be focused on how
you can make this
happen for you.
So let me take a step back and
say, why is Google doing this?
If you think about it, searching
the web is at its
heart a big data problem.
Google had to learn very quickly
how to store data very
reliably, very effectively,
and to go from
that data to meaning.
In other words, to understand
the core insights
hidden in that data.
And to be able to share it with
the world when we solve a
search query, or to share it
with our internal developers,
engineers, operations folks.
We were trying to understand
what's going on with the
system and how we want
to improve it.
And we learned to do
this at an enormous
scale and very quickly.
And so really, over the years,
we've been building our
technology that it turns out is
really big data technology.
We released a number
of white papers--
MapReduce, the Google File
System, FlumeJava, Dremel, all
talking about the
infrastructure we were building.
And it turns out that those same
papers have turned around
and become open-source projects
solving data problems.
Hadoop, for example, is based
on our MapReduce technology.
So we thought, well, if we could
actually give access to
our expertise to the world,
could we make it easier for
people to build great
applications and
do more with data?
And so I want to propose that
the combination of four
services, three of which have
been in the market for a
little while and one that we
announced today, is actually a
great way to solve
this problem.
You can store your data
effectively, reliably, and
with high performance
using Cloud Storage.
You can build applications and
transform data using App
Engine or Compute Engine,
depending on
what your needs are.
And then you can analyze that
data very quickly, as Ju-kay
showed you a little bit earlier,
using BigQuery.
And so, to put that in the
context of the virtuous cycle,
the tools that you have are
really App Engine and Compute
Engine to build applications.
You can collect data using
a number of different
mechanisms, from Google
Cloud Storage to Log
Store in App Engine.
You can actually process data
very quickly and effectively
using App Engine or Google
Compute Engine.
Those of you who were in the
Compute Engine session this
morning saw a great
demonstration of, actually,
MapReduce running in the
cloud and doing an
amazingly fast sort.
And then you can analyze the
data very quickly and
effectively using BigQuery.
So I'd like to pause here and
give you an idea what that
looks like in production.
And to do that, I'd like to
introduce Richard Verhoeff
from Crystalloids,
a BI company.
And he's going to show you a
great application that they
built using the Googlestack.
RICHARD VERHOEFF: Thank
you, Navneet.
So my name is Richard
Verhoeff.
I'm from Crystalloids
Innovations, and I'm the
co-founder of Crystalloids
Innovations.
We developed an application
called Inside OS, and we have
built it on the stack you've
just been shown.
The first customer we did this
for was a hospitality
organization.
It's called CenterParcs.
I'm not sure if there are any
Europeans in the audience.
Some, so some may know.
And then for the American, you
can compare it a little bit to
a cruise liner.
So it's a company.
Hence the picture
of the children.
It's real for fun.
It's not a business-oriented
business.
It's a consumer-oriented
And they manage around
10,000 beds.
So every day, they try
to fill 10,000 beds.
And they operate restaurants
on their premises, hence it
looks a little bit like
a cruise liner.
So they have a great
captive audience.
And there's one thing,
they're about 45
years in business now.
They've created a huge European
customer database.
And from this, they accumulate
a lot of
knowledge about their customers.
And they were doing a lot
of data mining, a lot of
forecasting on customers
and who to
address in certain mailings.
So they were used to having
a lot of databases.
What happened with them?
So at a certain point, we were
involved in this project.
And they had a fairly good
overview of what they were
trying to achieve.
So they had a really done proper
design of what kind of
application they were
trying to achieve.
They had a lot of
internal tools.
They had a proper
data warehouse.
They had proper staging areas.
They even had business
objects run properly.
And the standard report
was very well.
So that was not a problem.
And then they started thinking
about doing slightly
different, combining a
lot of the reports.
They were scattered around
across all kinds of
departments.
Sales is concerned about
revenue, marketing about
customers, and the operators on
the villages about clients.
Others were concerned
about margins.
And what you see in large
companies in this scattered
world, they all have a slightly
different view on reality.
And a lot of discussions and
debates in that company.
So commercial guy said let's
bring this all together.
And by the way, if we've got so
much data and we determine
and predict on customers, why
don't we do this on revenue?
So you see here in the
first designs--
I think this is five,
six, years ago--
you saw a first design.
So what happened?
What you see in these large
companies, they start having
an architectural picture.
And of course, they want to
use proven technology--
so Netezza Data Warehouse,
Business Objects--
and let all the data flow.
Well, I was there at the time
and, I think, tried five or
six different solutions from
Microsoft Analytic Server to
Business Object itself.
It's too much to name.
And they had all one
thing in common.
They all failed.
Everything failed.
Everything that we tried,
everything failed.
And why did it fail?
Sometimes it was
too expensive.
It was a new insight.
Not something which you could
put there and it could earn
money, it was just insight.
I like to phrase, the benefit
of insight is insight.
You still need to do something
with the insight.
And if you don't do
anything with the
insight it's just insight.
So some of the vendors came,
yeah we can solve this problem
with your forecasting.
It will cost you 1 million euro
to just buy the software.
So that failed on the expense.
Another one was like, the
machine just stopped because
it didn't work.
And the other one, you increased
so much systems, you
increased system management so
much that the IT guys were
like, OK, sorry.
That's not acceptable.
So that all failed.
So we thought, let's try
another approach.
Completely different approach.
We almost abandoned the
project with them.
Just stopped.
I said, well, OK, let's
do it differently.
So what did we do?
First we thought, let's
do it differently.
So instead of having analysts
looking at the problem, we
took a developer to look
at the problem.
And we gave him one rule.
You're only allowed to use
Google technology.
And why did we do that?
In that company, they had some
experience with a transaction
application on Google.
And what was liked about it,
it was in the cloud, of
course, on the first machines.
And we learned about BigTable.
And we thought, well, if Google
can make such quick
applications, why not we?
Because they apparently seemed
to solve the solution.
So we started learning about
column-based databases.
And we thought, well, we'll
put all data in BigTable.
That didn't work either.
And then we were lucky.
Sometimes you have a break.
We learned about BigQuery.
And it looks like that
BigQuery will do.
But then there's always an issue
with a European company.
Google didn't allow
us to use BigQuery
because we were overseas.
So we had to persuade a little
bit more, get some more phone
calls, get the Google in
Europe working for us.
And finally, we were made
a trusted tester.
So we were, two years ago,
trusted tester on BigQuery.
And we set ourselves the rule,
only use Google tools.
So App Engine, Google Web
Toolkit, we found out that
there is a great chart
in APIs there.
And I still remember the
presentation from one of the
Google I/Os a few years ago.
There is an API for it.
So we thought, if we can't
fix it, let's limit
ourselves to Google.
So we did.
And we succeeded.
And I will show you, in a
minute, the demo of the
application.
The application Is there.
So it's an application which
is now also in other
hospitality services.
It's an application which
is being used by
the real end user.
So it's not a tool which we
implement for business user.
And I think what happened is
that the flow of all the data,
from all the back offices, is
now into cloud storages.
Some is being uploaded
into BigQueries.
Other stays in BigTable.
And suddenly, you get the
feeling like Google does with
customization or
consumerization.
And suddenly a BI became really
in the hand of, let's
say, the internal end user,
so not the consumer.
But you suddenly see how this
works for real people who have
not a technical background, not
even in computer science
or in more technical marketing
departments.
And they suddenly can go
through all the data.
So let me show you
now the demo.
We have to switch, I think.
So bear one second with me.
So I take, now, one viewer.
And what is this viewer?
If you're in travel, people book
today for a holiday in
six months, of course.
So what you see on the
screen is how--
and this is on demo data--
how the bookings of last week
are for the future.
So we had this idea.
So we would like to look
backwards, of course.
So what did happen?
What did we [? brought in ?]
in sales?
And where will it land?
So what you instantly see here
is that on this we put
together a few years of data.
And we compared July last year
with July the year before, and
it instantly showed
up the graphs.
I don't have that much time.
So what I will do--
you saw that July was behind,
or I will tell you that July
was behind.
And I will move to
a different view.
I'm going to select now the
month of July and apply this.
And what Ju-kay just did
with the BigQuery,
this is BigQuery work.
So picking July in the
background, it generates, of
course, a BigQuery query, and it
just picked on the month of
July of the last three years.
This is for normal business
users who use Excel.
Very difficult to do, and
especially when you see, well,
I thought July was behind.
But apparently it's
not behind.
So how come?
Well, maybe there's a
difference in weeks.
So here I apply the
last week of July.
And it compares to the same
week of July last year.
And these are actually--
every time I hit apply, it goes
back to the back end.
And it comes up with the data.
There is no data here, which
I don't understand.
So let's do it again.
Yeah, so it's not
the second week.
So maybe it's the first week.
And this is the way end users
want to understand their data.
So I've just done a lot
of data queries.
And then you see July is behind
in the first week, but
I saw a bigger difference.
Well, where's the difference
coming from?
If you operate in Europe, and it
must be the same in United
States, you've got States.
In Europe you've
got countries.
So lets interrogate
some countries.
Well, there are a lot
of countries.
This company has from these
countries and areas
[INAUDIBLE].
So I will drill it down.
And what you saw in Ju-kay's
demonstration is now the
effects from the back end.
So this is real fetching it.
So wow, there's a lot
of countries here.
Going to make it slightly
easier, because I
want to zoom in.
I know already I want to zoom
in on a certain region.
And I thought, well, maybe it's
Germany that's causing
the problem.
So, yeah, Germany was
causing the problem.
So here, suddenly, the end users
making now queries to
the back end and having
an overview in
a very simple view.
Then you wonder, well,
what's caused this?
Let me see, is there
a certain region
which causes this problem?
And I know, because I prepared
this, of course, that there is
a certain region that's
causing this problem.
And now, in the hand of the
end users, they are using
BigQuery without having any
knowledge about SQL,
[INAUDIBLE], tooling,
cross tabulations.
And it's so quick for them
that sometimes--
when we first had this
application running, I still
remember that one of the Germans
said to me, when it
was customer implemented,
[SPEAKING GERMAN], which
means, in good English, what
system do you look in?
Because I don't know where
you get the data from.
Because they were looking at the
old reports, the green and
red reports from Business
Objects, and they couldn't
figure out where I got
the data from.
We had this conference call,
and during the meetings, I
could look through their data
and tell them from what
agents, for instance, in the
countries or what actions,
like was the booking made
on the internet.
Was the booking made
in a call center?
Was the booking made via
the travel agents?
What kind of actions revolved
around making this graph?
And if an end was thinking,
OK this is about Germany.
But what about Belgium?
Well, in the old days, we
would have gone to the
business analyst guy.
Had to ask him, can you do
this again for Belgium?
And then he would look at me
like, OK, so you just asked me
to do everything on
this on Germany?
And now you want me-- yeah,
and can you have it today?
Well what's here now is
really you do it--
[? is it OK? ?]
OK, you just push this
one and you've got
Belgium and Germany together.
So instead of doing minutes
or hours or a no answer on
traditional data warehousing
tooling, instead of waiting
days on schedule reports,
you can interrogate.
And I have to say, there is
about 40 million rows
underneath this demo
in BigQuery.
So it's not a Google set.
But it's still, for a company,
a large set.
The real end user, who's
using the tool, and not
the business analyst--
and I made some calculations.
Not buying all the new software,
not buying all the
hardware, saved about $800,000
in a project.
So they are very pleased
with the tool.
Thank you.
NAVNEET JONEJA: Thank
you Richard.
So I mean, you could imagine,
that taking data and turning
it from a turnaround time of
hours to a turnaround time of
seconds fundamentally changes
what you think you can do with
your business, because you
can react to end users
almost in real time.
You can adjust your business
to deal with what you're
hearing and seeing from
the market now.
So let me quickly--
very quickly--
give you an overview of the
services we talked about.
The data was stored in
Google Cloud Storage.
Multiple layers of redundancy.
Like all the services, powered
by the Google network, which
is extremely reliable and high
performance, built to serve
our own sites over several
years, and we
think it really shows.
You can store as much
data as you need.
So as your data needs grow, and
as you decide you want to
bring more data to bear, you can
do that without worrying
about capacity and provisioning
and over capacity
and overspend and underspend.
And you can share data quickly
and effectively.
You can use App Engines, various
tools, to both build
applications as well as
transform your data.
You can actually even make use
of what's by far the world's
largest hosted NoSQL database,
the App Engine Datastore,
which effectively gives you
the ability to store
structured data, and query it
effectively and quickly,
without having to worry
about schemas.
You can have atomic
transactions, but you can get
that at the expense of
giving up the ability
to join across tables.
But the good news is you could
actually do joins in the
cloud, especially with large
data using either App Engine
or using Google Compute
Engine.
If you already have invested
time, money, technology, in
the Hadoop ecosystem, you can
bring that to the cloud now
and write in the Google cloud
close to your data and go
from, again, your raw data to
your processed data so you can
now actually make sense of
your data very quickly.
And then finally, we talked
a lot about BigQuery.
But the bottom line is, that's
where you actually get the
insight from.
So putting that all into the
form of an analytics pipeline,
you store your data in any
number of places, depending on
the kind of data you have.
If it's structured, it
ends up in Datastore.
If you're trying to gather
application logs from App
Engine, you can store
it in Logstore.
Or you could use Google Cloud
Storage for storing any
generic data you have.
You can then transform and
process it using either App
Engine or Google
Compute Engine.
And then you can create it using
BigQuery so that you can
build your applications.
So as Ju-kay spoke a few
minutes ago, there are
multiple ways to do this.
There's open source.
There's proprietary
technology.
We feel that both of them
have their drawbacks.
Or you can just use
the Googlestack.
So all of the technology you saw
today looked like a very
well-integrated suite of
products, because it is.
But it turns out, you don't
have to use all of these
products together.
You can use them individually.
Each of them has
their own API.
And to talk more about how you
can actually use an API to
build a great application, I'd
like to invite one of our
partners, Nicolas Raspal,
to talk more.
NICOLAS RASPAL: Thank you.
So my name is Nicolas.
I'm the CTO of a company called
Bime, and our mission
is to deliver business
intelligence via the cloud.
So really, our goal is to
improve our business users to
analyze the data at any scale
without having to think about
technology.
So we do that through
a very intuitive and
powerful user interface.
And I will show you that
in a couple of minutes.
So we connect to a lot
of data sources.
We connect to relational
databases.
We connect to App Engine, Google
spreadsheet, Google
Analytics, so we try to really
embrace where IT is today.
And we were in a quest.
We were in a quest to find
something like BigQuery.
So it's kind of a
bold statement.
We really think that BigQuery
is the revolution.
Why?
Because, as I said, we
were in a quest.
We tried a lot of different
technologies to be able to do
BI queries.
So BI queries, if you think
about it, it's a large range
query that aggregates
a lot of data.
So typical queries give
me the sum of profit
over time, for example.
The second characteristic
is it has to be
really, really fast.
The problem is most of the
technology that was available
is kind of expensive.
As Ju-kay mentioned, it can be
expensive or complex if it's
open source.
With BigQuery, basically, it
removed all those obstacles.
You get very scalable
back end to do all
your kind of queries.
So, seeing is believing.
So we tried to show to you a
really quick, very quick, demo
of what we can do on
top of BigQuery.
If you can help me, Ju-kay.
OK, wonderful.
So we are in a web
browser here.
And I would just pick
up one connection
available in this account.
And what you get on the left
here is all the column
available in the BigQuery
database.
And the way you do query,
it's really simple.
You can just grab a column, and
you drop it to the layout.
And by doing that, you
do your first query.
So here, I just sent all
the quantity available.
So we are in a retail
data set.
So if I switch the aggregator,
so here, we are [? Houston, ?]
but if I switch [? to counts, ?]
we would
count the number of rows
available in this data set.
So we are sitting on top
of a billion rows here.
So as you can see,
it's really fast.
It's live.
No trick.
No prior aggregation.
Everything is done on the fly.
So as I said at the beginning,
we really tried to improve our
business users.
So for a long time we'll forget
that we are sitting on
a really large data set.
It's not gigantic, but for a
live demo it's kind of-- well,
that's the first thing that
BigQuery can give you.
You can do demo on very
large data sets.
And the first thing you want to
do when you think about a
data set like this is, what is
the time frame we are on?
So by just dragging another
column to the mix, I will
expose all the quantity
by year.
So this is it.
And I will switch to a different
visualization.
We are ready for queues
on that visualization.
We have 16 type of visualization
with hundreds of
customization points.
So you can do a map.
You can do relationship
on any of these.
You can do a tree map.
But for the sake of simplicity,
I will stick with
a simple column chart.
So these are the exact
same results but now
through column charts.
We see that in 2012, we don't
have a lot of data because
it's not done.
So let's break down into months
to try to picture the
trend of the data.
Here, we are working on sales
data set, but it can work with
pretty much anything.
It can be [INAUDIBLE] data.
It can be AdWords data.
It can be really anything and
you will get the same kind of
flexibility.
But let's go back
to this example.
We see that the other quantity
are pretty steady, except that
in April 2012 here we
have an increase.
So the goal of the demo is
to try to understand why
we have this peak.
So I can interact
with the chart.
I can really use the
visualization to interact with
the data that is stored
in BigQuery.
And each time I do something
like, well, I will decompose
this point.
I will go behind, literally
behind, this point and
decompose that by, let's
say, sales channel.
Each time I do something like
that, I'm [INAUDIBLE]
BigQuery, and I'm processing
something like eight
gigabytes, nine gigabytes
of data on the fly.
And wow, it's amazingly fast.
If you try to have this kind of
capability in house, and if
you try to do that for several
customers on the same
infrastructure, you have a
lot of pain to do that.
And this is what you
get out of the box.
Well, if you look at this chart,
we have the beginning
of an answer.
One of the sales channel is
holding most of the data.
So if I just switch to another
visualization, it's 90% for
one of the sales channels.
But, well, still we don't have
the complete answer.
We know that we have one
sales channel that is
holding a lot of data.
Maybe we can look at how it
compares with previous months.
So to do that, I can just grab
months here, move that to
another place in the
user interface.
And I'm going to use a
feature that we have
that is called Explosion.
And basically, it will generate
one chart for each
element in the explosion.
So here I'm going to select
several months.
And this will generate
one chart per month.
Here we go.
So I will just select
four months here.
And why am I doing that?
It's because you will see that
we will be able to compare
each month with each
other very easily
through different charts.
So again, step back.
We are [INAUDIBLE]
half a billion rows
on the fly.
We don't have to care about
the infrastructure.
We used this data set a
couple of days to go
to do a blog post.
I will show you that
at the end.
And we were pushing a dashboard
on the Google blog
post to potentially millions
and millions of users.
You can't do that in house.
You have to rely on someone like
Google to do this kind of
thing for you.
So here we go.
We have our four charts.
So let's [INAUDIBLE]
that a bit.
We have the answer
on this chart.
So the resolution is low.
I'm just switching
to another view.
This is January.
If you have a look at that,
the [? private-only ?]
shops that somehow doesn't
exist in January.
So I will move to
another month.
February, still doesn't exist.
March, still doesn't exist.
Wow, in April, where we have a
peak in terms of sales, we
have a new sales channel.
So that's kind of
the explanation.
Maybe our companion
have introduced
and used that channel.
That is working very well.
And that's the explanation.
Well, we have a beginning
of an explanation.
And my goal was just to show
you that you can really
interact with massive
amounts of data.
No prior aggregation.
No cache.
All the time we think about it
in terms of business, not in
terms of technology.
And a couple of months ago, it
was not doable to do this kind
of thing in the cloud.
And now I believe it's kind
of the tipping point.
Business intelligence is not
only doable in the cloud, but
it's a fun, better, faster,
and cheaper
than on-premise option.
Thank you.
JU-KAY KWEK: So I'm just going
to summarize very quickly.
But what Nicolas was showing, he
actually made it look easy.
I'm glad he pointed it out,
but that was a very
large set of data.
Using the set of tools from
Bime, or Richard showed
before, was a custom application
with a very
specific company and
domain focus.
It becomes, actually, quite easy
to actually transform and
shift our thinking from it's no
longer a technology problem
dealing with data.
We can really shift our focus to
where it ought to be, which
is solving a business problem.
We talked about the technologies
that Navneet
brought us through.
Nicolas demonstrated how to
build on top of APIs.
And what we also realized is
it's very important for
businesses that there's a strong
ecosystem to support
them as well with other
kinds of tools.
So I just wanted to highlight
this, that we're also working
with a fairly broad array of
partners in the data storage
space for things like NAS
replacement or online backup.
In the ETLs--
Extract, Transform, Load-- some
of the leading vendors in
that space, who are ready to
announce connectors into
systems like Cloud Storage
or BigQuery.
Take your data from on premises,
or in other parts of
the cloud, into our systems.
Make that really easy
and automatable.
And then as you just saw with
Nicolas, we have partners in
the visualization space as well
to make it really easy
with out-of-the-box, to slice
and dice really, really big
sets of data, quickly get
to those insights.
So just a quick summary.
What we went through was we
talked about some really big
data problems.
Hopefully one of the takeaways
that you have is that it's
really about focusing on solving
business problems
rather than building
technology to
just analyze data.
For the line of business, it's
important to remember that
using Google Cloud services,
you can actually start
relatively small.
You don't have to build
out a big data
infrastructure from day one.
Google Cloud services lets you
take an incremental approach.
And we'll scale with you.
That's true from everything from
Cloud Storage, BigQuery,
App Engine, Compute Engine.
And you get really, really
big applications as well.
Really important, the more
questions that you can ask,
the smarter those questions
become.
This is kind of turning
the eye on its head.
It used to be that you had to
kind of know the questions
ahead of hand before you could
create the indexes and the
cubes and then serve that up
to the business users.
By putting data in the
cloud, that actually
turns it on its head.
This is something that we do
at Google all the time.
We start out not really knowing,
sometimes, what is
interesting in the data.
And it's only by asking lots of
small questions on really
big sets of data that we can
understand what's important.
And through these tools, we're
allowing you to do the same
thing with your data as well.
If you're in the technology
side, IT and development, hey,
this is new-school BI.
Store all the data.
Worry about joining
it, processing it,
analyzing it, later on.
That's really the name of the
game now, especially when you
have more things like social
media, firehose, you've got
mobile devices.
The name of the game now is just
finding a place to store
it all, and we provide you very
scalable systems to do
that with things like the
Datastore, Cloud Storage.
The cloud enables you to set up
pipelines to then process
that on an automated basis and
to do it very rapidly, build
these things very rapidly.
Finally, you can actually build
apps on your data to set
the data free.
Again, this is something
that's quite new.
It used to be that data was
trapped in traditional data
warehouse systems with a team
of analysts or IT people who
were kind of the gatekeepers
to it.
What these tools allow you to do
is actually open up access
in a secure way, in a scalable
way, to the rest of your
organization and actually
develop the specific
applications needed to solve
those business problems.
So hopefully this session
was useful today.
I'd just like to thank, again,
Bime and Crystalloids for
joining us today.
And thank you for your time.
And we're happy to take
any questions.
I did forget to make a plug.
We have some other great
sessions about big data.
We did, yesterday, have a
session on doing MapReduce
pipelines in App Engine.
The video should be encoded
and posted onto YouTube.
Tomorrow we have a deep dive
into BigQuery internals.
We have some of our engineering
team here to talk
you through some best practices
for doing really,
really, big, interesting
queries.
We've got a session on cloud
storage as well.
And we've also announced today
some really interesting
sessions on Google Compute
Engine, which is the new VMs.
If there are any questions,
please come up to the mics.
Thanks.
AUDIENCE: I think the question
is related to the querying of
App Engine logs, which was
announced yesterday in the App
Engine overview session.
Logs are very generic in nature,
but if you want to
analyze more specifically based
on the domain data that
you might have, based on some
business data, would you have
to write a specific set of API
to big data to have your own
data structure?
And if so, what are the
patterns possible?
Because BigQuery doesn't allow
throughput beyond three or
four requests per minute.
So do you have any patterns that
you'd want just relating
to something like mem
cache and writing it
dyssynchronously or something
like that?
JU-KAY KWEK: So the question
is about, I think, what are
some of the patterns for getting
logs data, which might
in a domain-specific format,
into BigQuery?
AUDIENCE: That's the first
part, and the second part
being the technical know how
of writing to the BigQuery,
because the throughput to write
is lesser in the case of
BigQuery per minute.
JU-KAY KWEK: So maybe part of
the second question is there
was a significant ingestion
throughput, which basically,
the way it works is you send
us an ingestion job.
And we'll put that on a queue.
And we'll process that when
free cycles come by.
It is subject to certain rate
limits, but through a
combination of compression and
parallel import jobs, you can
actually be importing
significant amounts of data,
hundreds of gigabytes
of data, at a time.
So give that a try and see.
To your question about preparing
data, I actually
highly encourage you, if you
didn't, to look at the
MapReduce pipelines session.
One of our developer of programs
engineers actually
walks through how you do some
basic preparation of data from
the Logstore and do
some massaging.
And I think the example is just
massaging some of the
date times.
But it's representative of
reformatting the data, putting
that into a MapReduce pipeline,
and adjusting it
into BigQuery.
AUDIENCE: That's the 27th?
JU-KAY KWEK: Building Into
Pipelines at Google Scale.
So check that one
out on YouTube.
AUDIENCE: Can you reveal more
detail about the Compute
Engine and this BigQuery,
how they work together?
JU-KAY KWEK: So if you look at
the updated sessions that were
posted today, there are a
significant number of sessions
on Compute Engine itself.
I forget which one, but it's
later today, there's actually
one where we actually have a
demonstration of running a
Hadoop job within Compute Engine
to extract a bunch of,
I think it's in a Wikipedia
revision data which is a
pretty large data set, and then
ingest that into BigQuery
as a practical use case.
So if you're interested in
Compute Engine for doing data
processing jobs like that,
I recommend that
you go for that session.
NAVNEET JONEJA: I just
put up the session
names on the screen.
If you see the bottom-right
corner, those would be
interesting sessions for you.
JU-KAY KWEK: If no other
questions, thanks for your
attention today.
NAVNEET JONEJA: Thank you.